I told you that yeah I remember you did
that oh well this is my story let's
pretend like you don't know that's a
hey everyone happy happy weekend we
probably make it just a quick video
today while we're driving off to our
campsite to share a childhood story that
that about each other that we don't know
so I'm going to share a story that Nina
doesn't know and she's gonna tell me one
that I don't know let's see what happens
so my childhood story is when I was I
want to say eight years old I discovered
that when you unscrew the on the tires
is a little cap when you take that cap
off and you put like a stick inside
it'll take out all the air so what I did
was I did it for almost all the cars on
my street one early Sunday morning I
went and and let out all the air of all
the tires on all the cars on my street
which is really bad I'm not actually
like imagine waking up on Sunday morning
and your car has been flat tires and
everybody on the street has flat tires
that's really bad what joke on you I
don't think I really understood the I
got be so pissed off that that happened
to me we can mention going outside and
your car has four flats that's like
ruins your day how do you been going get
you know you might have one spare tire
but anyway that's my story I don't know
why I'm not I'm usually like a I'm a
good person I don't know why I did that
anyway okay i will hold the camera and
drive or do you want to hold it needles
gonna tell her story you're gonna hold
it what's Nina story my childhood story
I don't know about you quite a bit
actually but the only thing I remember
is ever know I say I'm very tiny and
small short well there's a reason it's
because you are I am pretty short than
five tier that's short with shoes what
those shoes I've two of those shoes yeah
52 without shoes is that that's pretty
short I felt like we need to do another
measure I know thanks anyway so if I
growing up me and my brother worthy or
always the
yes and Tates people in in the village
well at first of all I feel from a small
village by me and my brother we always
came from a we all we were always the
tallest and because the kids in the
village every time when I go to every
every year I have to sit at the back in
the class I'm always the last roll last
person at the fire because everyone is
everyone in my class they're so short
and tiny but ok ok wait why wait south
so then did you just stop growing and
they caught up or do you come from a
town of just tiny tiny people but it's
something in the water what happened I
think I think it's mix I think it's
mixed I think I stopped growing when I
was 11 years oh yeah that's not really
no it's amazing my story ever that's not
very nice ok ok cool well so yeah that's
my story that's awesome those are two of
our childhood stories i want to know a
childhood story about you something oh
that's a big bump I want to know a
childhood story about you something that
people may not know about you something
fun leave it in the comments below and
we're going to join the discussion thank
you guys for watching have an amazing
weekend we are off to the cottage
believe and we'll see you soon hi